Public Sénat en partenariat avec le
Centre national du livre vous présente
au bonheur des livres
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans l'émission
littéraire de Public Sénat au bonheur
des livres Joseph Kessel consomme
nommait Jeff et Romain Gary se
connaissait et surtout avait un certain
nombre de points communs ils étaient
d'origine russe tous les deux ils
avaient passé une partie de leur
jeunesse à Nice ils avaient des mers
sinon abusives du moins très présentes
ils ont été tous les deux des
casse-couilles des aviateurs de guerre
résistants gaullistes
ils ont été tous les deux de grands
écrivains à la fois couronnés de succès
et reconnu consacré mais surtout surtout
ils avaient l'un et l'autre ils ont eu
l'un et l'autre une écrit une existence
romanesque une vie plus grande que la
vie comme dirait les anglo-saxons et
c'est d'ailleurs le titre que nous avons
donné à cette émission et pour parler
d'eux deux auteurs qui se sont
intéressés à ces personnages hors du
commun
bonsoir
Kervin vous êtes haut fonctionnaire et
vous êtes homme de lettres un peu comme
garée vous êtes engagé dans une trilogie
sur Romain Gary dont vous avez publié le
premier tome en 2021 qui couvrait la
période où Romain Gary était consul de
France à Los Angeles et là vous faites
paraître le second tome monsieur Romain
Gary écrivain réalisateur chez Gallimard
dans lequel vous couvrez la décennie 60
celle dans lesquelles il revient à Paris
écrit s'intéresse au cinéma et vu dans
un couple de légende avec Jean cyberg
mais nous allons commencer avec vous
Dominique Bonnat bonsoir madame je
devrais dire maître car vous êtes
académicienne
d'ailleurs on devrait dire maîtresse en
vérité mais enfin bon je passe là-dessus
vous êtes une romancière vous avez été
lauréate de plusieurs prix l'intera lié
le Renault dos pour un autre roman mais
vous êtes aussi biographe vous avez
d'ailleurs fait une biographie de Romain
Gary mais vous êtes intéressé à des
personnages aussi différents que Valérie
André Maurois
Claudel Paul et Camille et d'autres
encore et là vous publiez chez Gallimard
vous aussi c'est l'émission Gallimard
vous publiez chez Gallimard vous aussi
les partisans dont lequel vous vous
intéressez à Joseph Kessel à Maurice
Druon et un autre personnage que j'ai
découvert pour ma part
Germaine Sablons on va y revenir vous
partez en fait d'une scène inaugurale en
1942 lorsque Joseph Kessel qui a presque
45 ans
commençons par Kessel son neveu le
surnomme c'est très drôle tolstoïevski
parce qu'il considère qu'il a à la fois
la force vitale de Tolstoï et le côté
sombre de Dostoïevski
et c'est tel qu'on le découvre dans
votre livre c'est un ogre des bonheur
grand amateur de femmes grand amateur
d'alcool grand amateurs de fête grand
amateur d'aventures de bagarres de
danger aviateur reporté un de guerre
écrivain d'aventure
très tout très français très russe très
juif très peuple
plus grand que la vie
oui c'est un c'est un personnage
magnifique que Joseph Kessel c'est vrai
et quand on suit ses aventures on ne
peut que à la fois l'admirer l'aimer et
s'inquiéter de le voir justement vivre
dans les débordements dans les excès
c'est un homme qui a sa légende il a
cette légende russe d'abord parce qu'il
aime les chansons de cigales la vodka
les fêtes qui n'en finissent pas c'est
un baroudeur qui a traversé la planète
qui a aimé tous les pays du monde qui a
eu des amis dans tous les pays du monde
mais ce qu'on s'est moins c'est que
c'est un personnage qui est assez
fragilité
il vit avec ses 10 boucles il appelle
dibook ces démons intérieurs donc c'est
un homme qui est quand même rongé par
une certaine série de culpabilité
d'angoisse principalement familiale
d'ailleurs et que l'on peut lire par
exemple dans un de ces livres qui
s'appelle le tour du malheur et qui est
largement
alors Maurice Druon est assez différent
je dois dire alors d'abord il est le
fils illégitime quel est son lien qui
est celle qui est le fils illégitime le
plus jeune frère de Kessel qui est mort
s'est suicidé quelque temps d'ailleurs
après la naissance de Maurice ruon il a
été adopté par le mari de sa mère qui
est une actrice un peu lointaine enfin
un peu évanescente qui était lui un
rejeton d'une bonne famille du Nord plus
ou moins aristocratique il est lui aussi
courageux il s'engage lui aussi dans la
résistance il est lui aussi écrivain
auteur de best-seller on a oublié mais
il a publié les rois maudits les grandes
familles enfin des livres qui se sont
vendus à des millions d'exemplaires donc
c'est un écrivain très très
couronné de succès
mais il est très différent de de Joseph
Kessel de son oncle au sens où
il m'apparaît moi je me trompe peut-être
mais snob
un peu honteux de ses origines
recherchant absolument la reconnaissance
sociale il aime les femmes mais près de
préférence de la haute société c'est
important de dire en effet que Kessel
est druyons sont oncles et neveux parce
que ce livre est né vraiment de ce lien
familial important entre Kessel et Druon
il y a un lien quasi filial il y a
admiration tendresse affection
complicité ce sont deux écrivains qui
vont marcher côte à côte vraiment à
partir d'une certaine date dès que Druon
se met à écrire à l'âge de 20 ans lui
aussi et donc ce lien de fidélité pour
moi il est la source même de ce livre
alors sur l'image de Druon oui Druon on
le voit aujourd'hui
tel qu'il nous est apparue ministre des
Affaires culturelles du temps de
secrétaire perpétuel de l'Académie
française c'est-à-dire un personnage
très officiel qui regarde la vie de haut
etc mais lui aussi et c'est l'intérêt
d'écrire des livres biographiques c'est
que on ne reste pas sur la statue de
bronze on ne reste pas sur la légende il
faut casser la légende il faut aller
vers l'homme et en vérité l'homme Druon
est beaucoup plus attachant que sa
réputation parce que c'est un bon vivant
lui aussi comme Kessel parce que lui
aussi aime la vie vaste mais simplement
sur les démons de la tribu Kessel il a
construit les garde-fous il a conçoit un
temple grec et il est lui à l'intérieur
de ses colonnes doriques j'ai noté vous
les efforts considérables que vous
faites pour pour redresser son image et
en effet par certains égards vous
arrivez à rendre sympathique le
troisième personnage alors que j'ai
découvert moi et qui est éminemment qui
est tout simplement épatante c'est
Germaine
sa blond donc elle est la sœur de Jean
Sablon chanteur qui a lui aussi un peu
disparu aujourd'hui mais qui est une
stérilité de l'époque elle est très
célèbre elle-même et elle est courageuse
elle est honnête elle est droite elle
est joyeuse elle elle va faire une
guerre merveilleuse elle quitte
d'ailleurs Kessel pour s'engager dans
l'armée d'Afrique elle ferait une guerre
absolument incroyable elle est maltraité
par Kessel qui est celle d'ailleurs
c'est mystérieux que celle-là quitte au
lendemain de la guerre définitivement ça
serait une blessure dont elle ne se
remet pas
en tout cas je vois qu'elle vous a
séduite et c'est vrai c'est une c'est
une femme magnifique parce qu'elle a du
tempérament elle a du courage elle sera
résistante la première des trois
puisqu'elle s'engage dans un réseau des
elle quitte elle aussi qu'elle d'une
certaine façon pour s'engager avec les
Forces Françaises Libres elle est
ambulancière pendant toute la guerre
autrement dit elle est sur le terrain
des combats au plus près de des soldats
des soldats blessés meurtri par la
guerre et cette chanteuse qui était
appelée à voir une carrière française
mais aussi internationale qui était à
l'époque aussi connu que Joséphine Baker
ou Mistinguett bien elle va après la
guerre tout simplement
abandonner la scène abandonnée cet appel
de la gloire pour vivre une vie beaucoup
plus calme dans le sud du côté de
Saint-Raphaël la guerre autant que la
rupture avec elle l'aura certainement
brisée je trouve tout de même après vous
avoir lui que en tout cas des deux qui
est célèbres je reviens à ça celui qui
sentir le mieux tout de même c'est que
c'est le Kessel bon moi je dois dire que
que j'ai toujours aimé ce personnage et
que j'ai presque appris à lire avec en
lisant fortune Carême et en le lieu on
vous lisant on se dit comme j'aurais
aimé le connaître comme j'aurais aimé
être son ami il sentir le mieux par
rapport à Druon d'abord parce que son
œuvre survit mieux que celle de Druon on
lit encore aujourd'hui forte une carrée
carré on lit les cavaliers on lit
l'armée de des ombres chauds je suis pas
sûr qu'on lise encore Druon et par
ailleurs ils sentir le mieux parce que
c'est un personnage libre qui ne
dissimule pas ce qu'il est qui assume
ses contradictions qui assument ses
origines et même à la fin de sa vie vous
raconter
sa dernière compagne très difficile
alcoolique qui l'ont fait voir de toutes
les couleurs et la persévérance avec
laquelle il aime témoigne justement de
la sensibilité que vous évoquiez de
cette humanité très forte de caisselle
une immense humanité il ressemble à une
montagne de tendresse Joseph Kessel mais
il ne faut pas sous-estimer son neveu
qui tient quand même un peu quelques
traits de cette oncle et
aujourd'hui encore Druon a des lecteurs
lui aussi à travers les rois maudits
parce que l'héro maudit c'est l'ancêtre
du feuilleton télévisé il a écrit ce
roman donc en plusieurs tomes avec toute
une équipe comme on fait aujourd'hui
pour les séries télévisées et donc il y
a une conception assez pionnière assez
industrielle finalement de la
littérature et est-ce que c'est ce
phénomène là mais on sait que les rois
maudits c'est quand même l'ancêtre de
Game of Thrones absolument postérité
tardive mais brillante de de Druon
vous voyez un air de ressemblance entre
Gary et Kessel oui peut-être un
tempérament à la fois slave et
méditerranéens ce qui peut sembler en
apparence un paradoxe mais plus encore
une éthique de l'action
entre deux tempéraments
intègre et engagés dont l'oeuvre est un
écho aux événements du siècle et ce qui
est singularise également
parce que ils n'ont pas seulement été
dans le grand roman l'un et l'autre mais
ils ont cherché d'autres formes
d'expression littéraires y compris pour
être au plus près des lecteurs avec le
journalisme en particulier la tradition
du du grand reportage ce qui en fait
peut-être deux figures singulières dans
la constellation de la NRF et le cinéma
aussi ils se sont intéressés l'un et
l'autre au cinéma les partisans
Dominique Bonnard c'est une incroyable
saga aventure de du lion comme on
surnommait Kessel et de sa tribu de ce
qui de la vie qui est autour ça
fourmille de d'anecdotes de récit mais
au-delà de ça il y a une profonde
comment dire j'ai un port un portrait
sensible de ces trois personnages et qui
les rend très attachant au point je le
répète qu'on regrette de ne pas les
avoir connus
Carvin vous vous intéressez dans
Monsieur Romain Gary écrivain
réalisateur à Romain Gary vous
reconstruisez vous reconstituer la vie
de Romain Gary depuis son retour
d'Amérique où il était consul de France
vous reconstituez son existence dans la
décennie 60 à Paris
ils disons depuis son retour de Los
Angeles jusqu'à la mort du général de
Gaulle d'abord première question
qu'est-ce qui fait qu'un jeune homme
presque un jeune homme s'intéresse
à Romain Gary au point d'écrire sur lui
une trilogie c'est une dette de lecteur
avant tout la lecture à l'âge de 18 ou
20 ans la promesse de l'aube de la vie
devant soi les Racines du ciel les
cerfs-volants et puis on a rencontre
également avec le travail de Dominique
Bonnat qui qui a tant fait pour
comprendre le personnage sensible qui
était Romain Gary et toute la portée de
son œuvre
m'a fait contracter auprès de cet auteur
une envers celui qui plaçait plus haut
que tout le pouvoir de l'imaginaire qui
pouvait bousculer tous les déterministes
bousculer ce qu'un personnage de la vie
devant soi appelle les lois de la nature
et j'ai commencé à travailler sur la
figure de Gary d'abord dans le cadre
universitaire en m'intéressant à
recoudre en réalité l'homme et son œuvre
en particulier pour sa période
diplomatique 15 ans au cours desquelles
il aura développé une véritable acuité
politique face au totalitarisme face à
la guerre d'Algérie et en travaillant
sur ses écrits de Diplomat sur ses
écrits politiques j'ai eu la volonté en
quelque sorte de le réhabiliter comme un
écrivain d'idée et le mettre au regard
de tous les événements que le diplôme a
traversé et qui font écho à son oeuvre
alors dans la période que vous couvrez
60-70 il y a évidemment un personnage
central pour lui c'est Jean cyberg parce
que
cette jeune américaine explose dans le
cinéma français de l'époque parce
qu'elle est l'héroïne de la nouvelle
souffle il forme un couple
d'abord un peu difficile parce que une
grosse différence d'âge ils sont sous
les spotlights de l'actualité il se
marie secrètement encore soyez toute une
aventure romanesque mais enfin c'est un
couple de légende dans le Paris de
l'époque un couple de légende à
Saint-Germain-des-Prés depuis que le
couple s'est installé au 108 rue du Bac
et ce qui m'intéressait d'explorer c'est
au-delà de l'intimité entre deux
légendes toutes dévorer par par leur
œuvre respective de voir l'influence de
la littérature sur le cinéma et du
cinéma sur la littérature car je crois
que la relation
conjugale qui a unie Romain Gary à Jean
cyberg a beaucoup fait pour son œuvre et
a contribué également à transformer la
façon d'écrire qui a eu Romain Gary à ce
moment-là on sait qu'il suivait beaucoup
de ginsyberg sur les plateaux tournages
on a des photos de presse le voyant dans
des fauteuils de réalisateur des Loges
d'acteurs la suivante aux quatre coins
du monde Gary a alors au début des
années 60 moins de temps pour se
consacrer au roman il va défendre vers
des formes littéraires plus brèves que
sont la nouvelle et il va avoir à ce
moment-là la volonté d'être
véritablement un artiste total c'est
intéressant un jour au théâtre le
lendemain
avec un succès mitigé d'ailleurs avec un
succès mitigé le lendemain au cinéma et
il va avoir la volonté pour Jean cyberg
pour lui donner un grand rôle dans un
film écrit sur mesure à un moment nous
sommes en 1966 où elle connaîtra de
moindre succès à un moment il voudra
véritablement lui donner un rôle titre
et la fera tourner dans dans les oiseaux
vont mourir au Pérou ce film qui a sa
place entière dans l'oeuvre de Romain
Gary une œuvre très sensible très
personnelle disparu et qui qu'il m'a
porté de revisiter par les témoignages
de l'assistant metteur en scène qui a
travaillé avec Romain Gary sur ce
tournage l'autre personne a centrale de
la permis de Gary à cette époque là
c'est le général de Gaulle et d'ailleurs
vous raconter un certain nombre de
scènes très drôle dans l'une dans lequel
il y a un déjeuner ou un dîner à
l'Élysée je ne sais plus et le général
de Gaulle change les étiquettes pour
être sûr d'avoir Jean siberg à sa droite
et passe le déjeuner à converser avec
elle et le ministre des pays étaient
caisson jeudi pété comme on disait à
l'époque qui est son voisin s'offusent
que de ne pas pouvoir parler aux général
de Gaulle selon Guy et tout à coup il
entend le général de Gaulle qu'il y a
oui non je ne les connais pas je les
apprécie beaucoup j'aimerais bien les
connaître et lui dit mais mon général de
qui parlez-vous de Gaulle lui dit les
Beatles mais donc vous racontez
plusieurs épisodes mais on sent que il y
a l'amour pour Jean cyberg mais que mais
que le général de Gaulle est un pôle
d'irradiation pour garer totalement et
les deux bornes que vous avez rappelé
qui sont à l'ouverture du récit déjeuner
au Palais de l'Élysée et à la fin du
texte ces obsèques à
Colombey-les-Deux-Églises dans un
dernier salut militaire à la figure du
général sont véritablement une façon
d'en créer l'imaginaire du texte dans
celui de la France gaulienne et ce qui
m'a porté était d'incarner la relation
entre entre deux Gaules et Malraux comme
celle entre de gaulets et Gary par des
scènes de vide des scènes d'action des
dialogues qui sont reconstituées par le
fruit de mon imaginaire mais en puisant
dans des brides de correspondance privée
aux Archives nationales dans le cas de
la correspondance avec de Gaulle à la
bibliothèque littéraire Jacques Doucet
dans le cas de la correspondance avec
Malraux un travail sur les archives
sonores les archivina vous retrouvez le
phrasé du général sceptique de langage
et pour rendre une amitié une estime
mutuelle entre deux figures légendaires
sensibles au lecteurs on entend la voix
du général comme celle de Romain Gary
mais on voit aussi qui le sait
d'ailleurs c'est vrai de caisser il est
aussi entre l'action vous l'avez dit et
la rédaction nous on connaît le le Garry
de la fin enfin on se souvient du Garry
qui Bouddha par la critique
invente le personnage d'agent pour
renaître et obtenir un second prix
Goncourt ce qui n'a pas d'exemple et on
a l'impression que dans les années 60 il
est au sommet de sa gloire que c'est la
promesse oui en fait on sent qu'il y a
déjà non pas une panne mais qui a déjà
eu un doute sur sa capacité d'écrivain
une difficulté à écrire dès ses
époque-là totalement et c'est pour ça
que faisons le choix de cette trilogie
et de trois moments charnières de la vie
de Romain Gary cette décennie 1960 me
semble aussi importante pour comprendre
comment Romain Gary aura cette volonté
d'être un artiste protéiforme et ce sera
relevé à chaque fois de ces échecs on
s'en peine on l'a dit échec avec le
théâtre et chèque avec avec le cinéma il
y aura la volonté de se délier de sa
propre peau le l'image que l'école alors
la critique et de se réinventer à partir
du début des années 70 ou la plume d'un
autre ce qui donnera comme vous l'avez
dit l'affaire Émile Achard
Dominique vous avez donc été on l'a
rappelé la biographie de Gary quels
étaient les relations entre Kessel et
Gary quels étaient les rapports entre
ces hommes les relations entre Kessel et
Gary sont des relations d'amitié mais en
même temps des relations de l'aîné au
Québec les nez c'est Kessel bien sûr et
donc qui est celle porte un regard
bienveillant sur ce jeune homme qu'il
découvre avec ses premières nouvelles
toute première nouvelle Romain Gary
s'appelle encore au Mans cassesse et il
donne ses nouvelles un qui est celle
pour gringuard journal dans les années
30 qui aura une évolution fâcheuse par
la suite mais qui dans les années 30 est
un journal intéressant qui mêle tous les
arts et donc
Gary sous le nom de cassef publiera de
nouvelles
donc gringouin grâce à Kessel et par la
suite il se retrouveront bien sûr à
Londres du moins à la fin de la guerre
et
donc essaie il y a ce regard toujours
bienveillant de caisselle vis-à-vis de
Gary est-ce que Gary était fasciné par
je me suis demandé s'il avait choisi par
exemple l'aviation parce que Kessel
était son modèle imaginaire ou si c'est
un pur hasard alors je ne sais pas parce
que je ne crois pas que Gary se soit
confié sur le sujet mais ce qui importe
c'est que dans la littérature française
il me semble que qui est seul et Gary
quand même peuvent être approchés je
crois qu'ils ont été victimes tous les
deux d'un regard trop sévère du milieu
littéraire de l'intelligentia comme on
dit parisienne parce qu'ils sont
différents et ils ont marqué cette
différence dans l'art du récit ce sont
deux grands conteurs ils ont cette plume
qui court sur la sur la page qui est
vivante qui est qui qui fait entendre
une voix on entend Gary on entend Kessel
on va poursuivre cette conversation avec
un jeune lecteur qui a la question à
poser à Kervin je crois
on l'écoute
[Musique]
bonjour je m'appelle Evra j'ai 21 ans je
suis en deuxième année de cursus à
centrale jupelec et je suis un lecteur
assez régulier et en suivant un cursus
scientifique lecture me permet un peu de
m'évader j'ai beaucoup de choses assez
diverses du roman au théâtre hôtel
classique j'aime beaucoup le théâtre je
voulais vous présenter un livre que
j'avais lu récemment qui s'appelle le
match de Kremlin donc le match du
Kremlin c'est c'est une sorte de fausse
biographie d'un conseiller proche de
Poutine qui s'appelle Vadim paranov et
on est un peu embarqué en fait dans les
arcanes du pouvoir russe cette Russie
qui sorte qui sort affaiblie à la suite
de l'effondrement de l'URSS qui
s'ouvre-libéralisme qui perd ses repères
et qui cherche en même temps à retrouver
sa place de grande puissance à travers
une figure forte celle de Poutine le
nouveau le tsark que Vadim veut faire
cette fausse biographie qui mêle des
faits avérés mais qui laisse en même
temps place à l'invention de l'écrivain
on le retrouve dans Monsieur Romain Gary
qui est le livre
lorsque j'ai lu votre livre j'ai tout de
suite pensé un peu à la promesse de
l'aube
justement Romain Gary dit que ce n'est
pas une autobiographie mais un livre
d'inspiration autobiographique est-ce
que vous avouez voulu un peu rendre
hommage à Romain Gary en copiant son
processus d'écriture en écrivant donc
cette biographie qui mêle à la fois des
faits historiques mais qui laisse
l'espace à l'imagination de l'écrivain
est-ce que Evra a raison tout juste
est-ce que votre identification à Gary
est-elle que que vous allez jusqu'à
imiter son son type de rapport à
l'écriture il y a dans cette façon de
s'inscrire dans les pas d'une légende et
de chercher à révéler son son intimité
sa grande sensibilité peut-être une
façon de grandir dans son ombre donc oui
il y a il a la dette dont je parlais il
est vrai que la promesse de l'aube est
un récit et Romain Gary il tenait comme
les la trilogie que je lui consacre mais
dans un genre différent puisque il un
jeu de collage effectivement
l'imaginaire permet de reconstituer des
des dialogues il y a un jeu de collage
en même temps entre des scènes racontées
et en même temps des fragments
d'archives des articles de journaux vous
êtes une biographie confirmée vous il y
a toujours une part d'imagination et de
romanesque même quand on cherche la
vérité biographie la plus la plus
précise j'aime bien la les limites de la
biographie la rigueur qu'elle
entraîne je crois que j'essaie de me
tenir au plus près de la vérité
historique du moins des documents des
sources des archives mais il est
impossible d'atteindre une sorte
d'objectivité de faire ça c'est
impossible et on est soi-même impliqué
dans le récit à la manière dont hervin
Spear l'exprime très bien dans ces deux
livres parce que ce sont de livres
sensibles qui aborde Romain Gary je
dirais par l'essentiel qui est le cœur
de Romain Gary beaucoup plus que
l'événementiel ou les renseignements
qu'il pourrait donner qu'il y a deux
types de journalistes les photographes
et les peintres les photographes
disaient-ils sont beaucoup plus près de
la réalité mais les peintres c'est
tellement plus beau je crois que c'est
un peu vrai pour la biographie aussi
voilà cette émission s'achève mais avant
que nous ne nous quittions je voudrais
que nous partageons avec ceux qui nous
ont suivis vos coups de cœur les livres
que vous auriez envie qu'ils lisent
attention c'est satisfait ou remboursé
il faut que ils soient pleinement
heureux du choix de lecture que vous
allez leur proposer on va commencer par
vous car win quel est le livre que vous
leur que vous soumettez à leur sagacité
bien un homme sans titre de Xavier
Leclerc chez Gallimard qui est le
portrait d'un père né en Kabylie et qui
par son itinéraire vers la France des
trentes glorieuses montrent
toutes les cueilles dont a dû se relever
une génération d'immigrés mais c'est
aussi une façon de répondre à Cam US
dans ce dans ce grand rêve d'une une
communauté fraternelle
Dominique Bonin alors j'ai lu un premier
roman formidable d'une jeune femme qui
s'appelle Perrine tripier et qui à peu
près une vingtaine d'années et qui écrit
un livre nommé les guerres précieuses
qui racontent l'histoire d'une maison
mais cette maison on ne sait pas très
bien où elle est il y a des sapins bleus
il y a des pommiers il y a des Lilas
cette maison va revivre en quatre
saisons dans l'imagination d'une très
vieille dame
enfermée dans une EHPAD privée de ce
lieu où elle a été heureuse ou s'est
déroulée toute sa vie et c'est un roman
à la fois sur l'extrême solitude sur la
vieillesse qui est d'autant plus
étonnante l'auteur est si jeune et sur
ce que peut représenter une maison pour
un être humain merci alors la rédaction
de au bonheur des livres a choisi pour
vous enfin vous tout le monde dans la
dans la dans le droit fil de la
conversation que nous avons eu Paul
Pavlowitch c'est Hajar en fait c'est le
neveu de Gary comme Druon était le neveu
de de Kessel autre ressemblance entre
ces deux hommes et qui a servi de prête
non mais puis ensuite qui a pris son
envol et qui raconte dans ses mémoires
des souvenirs très peu sur un jar
beaucoup sont jeans cyberg pardon
Patrick Chesnais qui est un
acteur de grand talent et là écrit un
livre assez drôle et sensible qui sont
des lettres d'excuse à toute une série à
la mort au petit matin que ça je mets
aussi des lettres très sensibles par
exemple à son fils qu'il a perdu
lorsqu'il avait une vingtaine d'années
donc c'est un mélange à la fois sensible
et drôle et gay une vision de la vie qui
est touchante et très agréable à lire de
la poésie on essaie de soutenir la
poésie Karen tuile
cadiche pour un amour c'est ce sont des
salles modulations
c'est le entre des des
prières religieuses et un chant d'amour
pour un homme qu'il a abandonné et donc
c'est la convergence de la
psalmodisation antique biblique et de la
de les fusion et du sentiment c'est très
touchant très très beau très très fort
et enfin
[Musique]
un roman graphique un roman noir par
johansfar Riviera donc johansford ou
écrire 3 à 4 livres j'allais dire par
semaine non mais pas par année et on
aime tous ces livres et donc on aime
celui-là voilà cette émission est
terminée merci de nous avoir suivis vous
pouvez la revoir sur le site de Public
Sénat ou bien sur votre plateforme
préférée et puis nous nous retrouvons la
semaine prochaine à la même heure à
moins que d'ici là nous ne nous soyons
croisés dans une librairie merci et
bonsoir
[Musique]
Public Sénat en partenariat avec le
Centre national du livre vous a présenté
au bonheur des livres